That's it get the hell up and Run Grodd. Run!
Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my flash season 6 episode 13
video probably one of the best episodes
of the series so far I was surprised at
how good it was compared to the last
couple of episodes especially there was
a ton of Easter eggs we had a really
crazy post credit seem so we'll break it
all down if you're new to the channel
we're doing a flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from the
episode on the video careful for
spoilers obviously if you haven't seen
the episode yet we'll do top 10 and
Easter eggs as we go along starting with
number 10 barry looking for his parents
graves so this is just a continuation of
all the crisis on Infinite Earths
aftermath that they're dealing with in
the back half of the season on all the
different DC TV shows they don't really
explain till later but barry has this
very Batman look on his face carrying
these flowers you know he's probably
going to someone's grave but when he's
underneath the overpass it's not really
evident where he's looking for who the
flowers are for but we find out that
because of crisis the location of their
graves change
Chester P Rrunk winds up helping him
find it later in the episode
speaking of which Chester P Runk is
back and it seems like he's going to be a
relatively permanent addition to team
flash at least in the back half of the
season or at least for the next couple
of episodes number 9 welcome back Pied
Piper we haven't seen pipe Piper in a
long time and obviously he's one of the
big changes because of crisis barry
tries to take him down but we find out
that now this new earth prime version
the new timeline changes he's a
metahuman so he still gets away and
apparently team flash did something to
totally did him over maybe they'll
address that in a future episode but
it's just a tee up for the theme of the
episode barry trying to deal with all
the changes to crisis and learning how
to move past all that run forwards as he
says later in the episode not run
backwards everyone post all your
flashpoint memes number 8 barry
creates a new version of Gideon so it's
slowly evolving remember Barry Allen
himself is the person who originally
created Gideon he learned that way back
in the first couple of seasons where did
you come from you created me Barry Allen
Morena Baccarin is still doing the voice
I think that's cool as big of an actress
as she has become she still does jobs
like this so it's still fun to hear her
voice when you hear it all the way back
to season one I'm assuming because
Chester P Runk upgraded it big time by
the end of the episode he'll just
continue using it but I'm not expect
Morena Baccarin to show up in every
single episode so even though he will be
using gideon technically every single
week we might not actually hear him
speaking to Morena Baccarin voice every
single week number seven mirror
master versus iris in the mirror world
so we finally got a bigger answer on
what's going on with this version of
beer master she does have a device she
can totally get through the mirror
anytime she wants but she's been lying
to Iris because she wants to use fake
iris to get information on Joseph Carver
and black hole they don't really explain
why it is and why she's trapped in the
mirror she seems like this damsel in
distress that needs to be rescued but I
wouldn't be surprised early theory is if
she wound up in the mirror under
different circumstances like maybe they
put her in there because she was too
dangerous or something like that
the way they tried to make her seem so
sympathetic the first couple of episodes
she appeared in just seemed like a bit
of a misdirect like we all know that
she's mere master we're expecting some
comic book Amir master things from her
I believe this device he or she uses to
manipulate the mirror is just an analog
for this version in the comics they
haven't completely explained what's
going on inside the mirror dimension
because now you have to wonder what
else's mirror master been lying about
but we'll probably find out in the next
couple of episodes because mirror master
does seem like one of the bigger
villains for this arc even though they
just tease reverse flash coming back so
number six was the reverse flash
caitlin reveal when barry wakes up
inside the mine space prison before he
realizes what's actually going on it's
just cool to see them it's pretty
instantly recognizable as the
reverse flash version of Harrison wells
is really not until she name drops
firestorm that you know exactly when in
the timeline you are during this scene
which she says Ronnie Raymond is
creating something he's calling it the
pipeline like oh wow this is clearly
happening before the events of season 1
I'm assuming that all the stuff that
he's experiencing inside here is from
grodd's memories so it really did happen
to Grodd and he did seem like he was
relatively mistreated by Harrison wells
even though technically when we saw
Grodd during season 1 season 2 he
referred to reverse flash as father
number 5 fake
iris lying to Joe stealing information
off of his computer on black hole we
don't know what it is that mere master
is trying to get on joseph carver and
black hole but obviously they're working
together either she created the fake
version of iris or somehow faked
iris just existed inside the mirror
world like I said it's not really clear
exactly what the rules of the mirror
dimension are are they're mirror copies
of everyone inside the mirror dimension
is that where fake iris came from number
four Grodd explains his version of
crisis on Infinite Earths he remembers
everything from the previous timeline
before the earth is merged I think just
because his mind was so powerful it just
protected him from the changes based on
the way Grodd explained everything to
Barry it did sound like he was trying to
be honest about changing like he just
wants to go home that was really what
sold it for me when he was like that was
the only time I was happy was when I was
in gorilla City please let me go home
the only thing that changed my opinion
of where he might be headed in the
future had to do with the merged version
of the flash I'll talk about that in a
second because that's a really deep cut
comic-book Easter Egg
but Grodd basically apologizes to Barry
for all the previous episodes like the
big gorilla city episode during season 3
season 4 season 5 usually they bring
back Grodd once per season and it's
usually been Grodd versus team flash
that's why six seasons in they try to
change the formula little bit in it's
Grodd flash team-up but because this is
all inside his mind space that's how
he's able to turn Barry's powers back on
instantly like I've given you you powers
back before Barry just punches him right
out on the spot number three was the
flash and Grodd merging firestorm style
to become the super gorilla speedster so
obviously this is super awesome super
weird and super comic book II they've
never done this in the comics but this
is a bit of an easter egg for the flash
rebirth story that involves black hole
early on when we knew that black hole
was going to be a big story element during
this season I wondered if they were
going to incorporate the Grodd part of that
story too because Grodd winds up being
the big architect that's behind black
hole
black hole in the comics is
experimenting in the Speed Force the
reason why is because Grodd wants the
Speed Force for himself because he
thinks he needs it to heal himself so it
becomes this big thing with a bunch of
flash villains Grodd winds up emceeing
all of team flash versus Barry Allen so
it's Barry Allen versus all of his
friends including god speed who he
breaks out of prison to help him that's
right Barry Allen breaking god speed out
of prison so obviously the comic book
storyline is a little bit different I
don't know if they're going to continue
to do that later
because when Grodd got the speedforce he
seemed like he really liked it and I'm
hoping that gives him the idea later on
hey wait a minute
I was so powerful when I had the Speed
Force it felt so good I kind of want to
do that again so maybe I'll try to take
the Speed Force from the flash now so
we'll see if they decide to pursue that
I haven't heard anything about that
though so there's early speculation you
also probably noticed the big callback
where Barry gives Grodd the pep talk
run Grodd run same pep talk that he's
gotten every single season sometimes
multiple times per season run Barry run
run Grodd run number two was the flash
Grodd versus so Lavar final battle just
an amazing fight scene probably one of
the best ones that the show has ever
done they do explain though that if they
don't separate them when they exit that
portal they will exit looking like that
looking like the merged firestorm
version of the flash and Grodd then
their minds will both simultaneously pop
like balloons so they find a way to
separate them and then Argus and Lyla
put a tracker on Grodd and let him go
back to gorilla city so that's where
he's now until we see him again on the
show I don't know if they're bringing
him back before to the end of the season
because it's really expensive to do the
special effects for Grodd so they might
just reference him in future episodes
maybe we'll see him again before the end
there was this whole big thing in the
episode about Chester P Runk team flash
it seems like he's joining team flash
even though Cisco they said is coming
back and I'm assuming this going to be
next week so I don't know if this is
going to be some sort of transition this
season with the actor who plays Cisco
leaving the show before season 7 and
Chester taking his place or them both
just being on Team flash it's just that
a lot of the things that Chester does
are the exact same things that Cisco
does and why would you have two of those
people on Team flash it just feels like
they're bringing him in to replace Cisco
eventually but obviously number one
was the reverse flash post credit scene
so they playing this really weird
storyline with Nash wells hallucinating
all the other alternate versions of
Harrison wells from the multiverse post
crisis this time though in this episode
he starts hallucinating Sherlock wells
and then at the end when he's getting
ready to confess to Allegra about his
daughter
Sherlock wells grabs him says he's
coming in his eyes start glowing red and
he's vibrating like reverse flash so
early theory this is where I'm hoping
they're taking this
hoping somehow Nash wells is connected
to the other versions of Harrison balls
from the multiverse but because of the
way he's hallucinating them they're
implying that they're inside his
consciousness somehow so maybe this will
be a situation where Nash wells winds up
being taken over by reverse flash his
body in Nash wells will effectively
become reverse flash they still haven't
explained where reverse flash went
during crisis on Infinite Earths why he
wasn't around was he in the negative
Speed Force hiding out that's the only
thing that would have protected him
because Oliver took the heroes into the
positive Speed Force to protect them
from the antimatter wave so I'm assuming
the same is true for reverse flash
inside the negative Speed Force but let
me know in the comments what do you
think is going on with the crazy mind
space version of reverse flash that he's
hallucinating here do you think they're
trying to set up the concept that
reverse flash will actually be taking
over Nashville's consciousness and just
taking over his body and that's how he's
going to come back but big news Wally
West is coming back in the next episode
the title is the death of the Speed
Force which is a comic book art but I'm
assuming the story of the episode will
be different from the comics so I'll do
a trailer video for that and then talk
more about reverse flash stuff because I
think it's all connected Wally West
coming back the weird stuff that's
happening with a Speed Force in Reverse
flash if you spotted any big easter eggs
in the episode that i didn't mention in
the video just write them below in the
comments everyone click here for my new
breakdown of that batman teaser and
click here for my brand new avatar the
last airbender Netflix video thank you
so much for watching everyone stay
awesome.
I'll see you guys tonight